what did you make of Jacob Riis mug they
he sounds quite sanguine about a cliff
edge almost I think what business is
looking for at this point is stability
and continuity because what financial
and related professional services firms
do is service customers and clients and
so continuity and stability is
absolutely vital are you calling for a
transitional agreement yes we are that
is a really important thing we need to
make sure that there's a bridging and an
adaptation period or implementation
period that allows business continuity
and again going back to customers and
clients that's what this industry is
focused in on so these comments from Sir
John Griffith Jones do you take any
comfort from the fact that the regulator
is preparing along those lines
well the regulator requires the firm's
that it regulates to provide details of
the plans that it has for any risk or
factor in the future that will require
significant changes to business planning
it's right that business looks at risk
surveys the future and of course what
business does is prepare for the worst
but hope for the best so this is a
natural business planning cycle do you
worry though that regulators like the
FCA are sufficiently well staffed to not
only carry out their day-to-day job
oversight of financial markets and so
forth whilst at the same time looking
ahead towards brexit one of the things
that the city UK has called for recently
is a renew partnership between
government regulators and business and
if one's looking to future scape that is
a really important thing to bear in mind
and what about your membership that
banks fund managers insurance companies
and so forth what did they make of Boris
Johnson's comments earlier this week
that the government's made no
contingency plans for a cliff edge well
at the end of the day business is about
continuity and that's what business is
focused in on at the moment this is not
a time to play big-ticket politics this
is the time for the business community
to focus on doing what the business
community does best and provide the best
service to its customers and clients
what's going on behind the scenes Oh
Gary I mean oh the FCA calling
right you in regularly and saying right
what are you doing I mean we know the
Bank of England's doing that it's the
sca
on that sort of case as well yes there's
a very rich dialogue between the
regulators and the industry the city UK
regularly sees both the PRA and the FCA
to discuss these issues we have been
involved in identifying issues and also
proposing some solutions to the issues
that we've identified on behalf of the
industry and what about Brussels this is
there much dialogue there because
clearly our leavin has a huge impact on
Brussels as well because the city is
Europe's premier financial center you
made a really key point there and with
London and the UK being not just the
world's leading international financial
center but Europe's financial center to
Brussels the EU member states need to
focus in on that because that is where
their businesses also get world class
services from finance and related
professional services I would leave it
on the freight Garrick app came from
city UK thanks for joining me